on the internet the other day I found an
animal that looks like something quite
familiar they've tried to block the road
but outside of the road once your turns
out this fluffy looking caterpillar that
looks super soft is actually super
poisonous so I called dr. Wagner
he's an entomologist up at UConn my
specialty is Lepidoptera which is the
study of butterflies and Maas this
caterpillar it has a few names
well it's Megillah Pidgey of perky
Alaris most people call this animal the
post caterpillar except in the south
where many people call it the ass these
caterpillars are distinct because
they're covered in what looks like long
soft hair only mammals have to here and
then what we find on insects are really
derived scales underneath so it's where
the poison spines are there may be a
little bit like a hypodermic needle when
you pet the caterpillar it's quite a
wallop I think of all the caterpillars
in stings the house may have the most
painful and most toxic sting that poison
can cause headaches swelling nausea
blisters even difficulty breathing and
in case you were thinking that these
guys probably live deep in some jungle
you would be wrong they're found mostly
south of the mason-dixon line so here's
a new adage to help you remember if it
looks like Trump's hair you better
beware